nine fun details from The Last of Us
episode 8. the ZIP code here is for
Durango Colorado a ski resort town just
like Silver Lake in the show The Man
Joel attacked at the end of episode 6
was Hannah's father and all Clues Point
toward her unknowingly eating her own
dad the actor who plays David is Troy
Baker who played Joel in the game in the
show Ellie slashes David 22 times
compared to 10 in the show and Joel
calls Ellie baby girl for the first time
the same thing he called his own
daughter Sarah in episode 1. almost
every member of David's Church has a
significantly religious name like David
Timothy or Josiah David says he left the
Pittsburgh quarantine Zone when it fell
in 2017. it's the same city where a
significant portion of the game was set
in the game Ellie wakes up to find David
carving up a human corpse while on the
show she uncovers this Mystery by a
leftover human ear in the game Jolene
covers a document that shows just how
many pounds of human flesh David and his
men collect each month for more videos
like this check out my channel think
Story on YouTube